if we can briefly look out into the next
hundred years on this
i apologize for the existential
questions
but
it seems obvious to me
that as gain of function type of
research and development becomes easier
and cheaper
it will become greater and greater risk
so if it doesn't no longer need to be
contained
within the laboratories of high security
it feels like this is one of the
greatest threats facing human
civilization do you worry that at some
point in the future a leaked man-made
virus may destroy
most of human civilization
i do worry about the risks and
at the moment where we have the greatest
control the greatest oversight
is when this is federally funded
research
but as you're eluding there's no reason
to imagine that's the only place that
this kind of activity would go on
if there was an evil source that wished
to create a virus that was highly
pathogenic in their garage
the technology does get easier
and there is no international oversight
about this either that you could say has
the same stringency as what we have in
the united states so yes that is a
concern
it would take a seriously deranged group
or person
to undertake this on purpose uh given
the likelihood that they too
would go down we
don't imagine there are going to be bio
weapons that only kill your enemies and
don't kill you sorry we're too much
alike for that to work
so
i don't see it as an imminent risk
there's lots of uh scary novels and
movies written about it but i do think
it's something we have to consider what
are all the things that ought to be
watched you may not know that if
somebody is ordering
a particular
oligonucleotide from one of the main
suppliers and it happens to match
smallpox
they're going to get caught
so there is
effort underway to try to track any
nefarious actions that might be going on
in the united states or international is
there an international collaboration of
trying to attract this stuff there is
some i wish it were stronger
this is a general issue like in terms of
do we have a mechanism particularly when
it comes to ethical issues
to be able to decide what's allowable
and what's not and enforce it i mean
look where we are with germline genome
editing for humans for instance there's
no enforcement mechanism there's just
bully pulpits and governments that get
to decide for themselves so you talked
about evil what about incompetence does
that worry you i was born in the soviet
union
my dad a physicist worked at chernobyl
that comes to mind that wasn't evil i
was
i don't know what word you want to put
it maybe incompetence is too harsh maybe
it's the inherent incompetence of
bureaucracy i don't know but for
whatever reason there was an accident
does that worry you of course it does
and we know that sars for instance did
manage to leak out of a lab in china two
or three times
and at least in some instances people
died fortunately quickly contained
all one can do in that circumstance
because you need to
study the virus and understand it in
order to keep it from causing a broader
pandemic but you need to insist
upon the kind of biosecurity the bsl 2 3
and 4 framework under which those
experiments have to be done
and certainly at nih we're extremely
rigorous about that but you can't count
on every human being
to always do exactly what they're
supposed to so there's a risk there
which is another reason why if we're
contemplating supporting research on
pathogens that might be the next
pandemic
you have to factor that in not just
whether people are going to do something
on that we couldn't have predicted where
all of a sudden they created a virus
that's much worse without knowing they
were going to do that but also just
having an accident that's that's in the
mix when those estimates are done about
whether the risk is worth it or not
you